-Our next guest is
the co-creator and star
of the Showtime series
"Work in Progress,"
which airs Sunday nights.
Let's take a look.
-Don't you dare move.
Trash can! Trash can!
Oh [bleep]
[ Shouts indistinctly ]
Oh, God, have I already [bleep]
this up?
You're so [bleep] sexy!
I can't stand it!
♪♪
-Where were we?
-Take me there, Bobby.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back --
Please welcome to the show
Abby McEnany.
How are you, Abby?
-Hey, Seth. How are you?
-This is -- I'm great.
-I still can't believe that --
-So, this is really something
here.
This is -- Obviously that was
Vincent D'Onofrio.
-I know!
-Your character is a fan of him,
but this is the real, true thing
about you your whole life.
-I don't know my whole life.
I'm very old.
A very long time. Yeah.
Oh, dude, yeah.
I'm very much a fan.
In fact,
for my birthday in 2010,
one of my friends made me this.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's my face over
Detective Eames' head.
Listen, yeah,
I can't even stand it.
I can't believe it.
It's crazy.
-So, you -- how did it happen
that you reached out
to Vincent D'Onofrio
and he agreed to do the show?
-Honestly, if you
ever talked to him,
I don't know why he agreed.
I don't --
[ Laughter ]
Also, I know this is so --
I'm so -- I'm so honored
to meet you.
Okay, I'm very nervous,
but this is really an honor.
So thank you for having me.
-I'm so happy to meet you too,
and we both came up in Chicago,
and we know a lot of
the same people,
all of whom speak very highly
of you.
-Okay, well, same here.
So maybe we need to do
some digging.
But anyways, like, really,
honor, it's been an honor --
it's been an honor.
You're still on.
Okay. Anyways, so, my --
you know, my --
my partner, Lilly Wachowski,
and she had met Vincent
a long, long time ago.
So, wrote a really lovely e-mail
to him and just kind of
explained the show and what we
were trying do this season.
And we reached out
actually in May of 2020.
And, you know, we -- we were --
we had like four different
start dates for season two.
You know, and so, once
we, like, knew our date
and we were like,
"Hey, we only need a day.
We'll fly to New York.
We'll do a green-screen day."
And he ended up flying here.
And I still, like, "Whoa."
-That's really cool.
Now, don't take this
the wrong way.
I have my doubts you were able
to keep your cool around him.
[ Laughter ]
How'd you do
when you first met him?
-I have to say, I thought
you were better at,
like, really
understanding folks.
No, absolutely.
It was -- It was outrageous.
We met him on -- We met him
on Zoom like the week before.
Lilly and I, like, and "Vincent"
Zoomed just to check in,
'cause, you know, here's, like,
this big star coming to Chicago
to do this thing for us,
and, you know, just finding out,
like, how he works and, like,
what could we do
to make the day better
and explain to him
what it was and stuff.
We actually have another really
fun guest star this year.
It's Audie Cornish from NPR,
who's just a -- holy smokes.
So, we met her on Zoom
in January.
So Lilly and then Blythe Haaga,
who is a producer
and one of our directors, and I
were talking to Audie on Zoom.
And I was kind of bouncing on
the couch, I was so nervous.
And then, when we were about
to meet Vincent,
I just told Lilly like,
"Hey, when it starts
getting like that,
just text me in all caps saying,
'Audie, calm down. Calm down.'"
And then, like, of course,
'cause I can't keep anything
to myself, I told Vincent that
about 15 minutes in.
-[ Laughs ]
-"Just so you know, I promise --
I asked Lilly to promise me
to tell me if I got too creepy."
-Well, obviously you didn't,
because he flew out to Chicago.
But I want to talk about
something
that's incredibly impressive.
Obviously, anytime someone
creates a show for themselves
that they write and star in,
that's a big deal.
But you had kind of never --
you sort of skipped
all the other steps.
This was, like, the first set
you had ever been on, right?
-Right. I mean, I would say --
like, skipping steps, I mean,
I've been doing this [bleep]
for a long time.
-Sure, yes. Understood.
-But, no. You know what I mean.
But, yeah, like, it's wild.
It's wild.
Yeah, I had auditioned
every once in a while.
Got to say, nobody wants
a big, old, fat, woman queer
to sell burgers.
You know what I'm talking about?
But I'm a really horrible
auditioner, too. Anyways.
So, yeah, it was -- it's wild.
The learning curve was bonkers.
Like, I still can't believe it.
And, you know, having
Lilly Wachowski,
who, you know, changed cinema
as your partner,
who really knows
how things work,
is, like, totally supportive.
It has been amazing.
Yeah, I learned stuff every day.
Every day.
And all these terms.
I was like,
"Is that an industry term?"
They're like,
"No, we're going to lunch."
I'm like, "Okay. Alright."
I don't know...
But everybody's -- like, really,
our crew's so wonderful.
-Chicago must be very happy that
you're doing the show there,
especially as you sort of
got your comedy start
there doing Second City.
I know you did Tour Co.
I'm always fascinated, delighted
to hear people's worst
Tour Co shows when they were
going around the country,
doing improv for people.
Do you have any particularly
bad ones?
-Well, yeah. We were in
University of South Carolina
once, and it was like the week
before school started.
So they have all these free
events for incoming freshmen.
And so, they booked Second City,
and we were playing --
it basically looked like one of
those hotel ballrooms
with the accordion doors.
It was just crap, right?
There were, like, I don't know,
rows and rows of chairs
that nobody was in.
And then our stage manager
couldn't really hear us.
It was like a crappy
pipe and drape.
And then the Fighting Gamecock
is their mascot.
So, the announcer was like,
"Okay, next up,
the Second Nation."
And then the Fighting Gamecock
is on stage, like, dancing,
and our, like, stage manager's
yelling, "It's Second City!"
And then the guy goes,
"Also, free Dippin' Dots."
So, then, like in the same room,
like, the 10 people that like,
"Free Dippin' Dots?"
So, at the end,
like at the back of this room,
there were about 150 people
in line for free Dippin' Dots.
Yeah, it wasn't
exactly seamless.
[ Laughter ]
-You have another cool
guest star,
which was Julia Sweeney,
who, of course, was
a celebrated "SNL" cast member
over the years.
She wrote and created
the character Pat,
who became, you know,
a character that was, you know,
criticized as the years passed.
And you reached out to her,
and she was willing to sort of
play ball and be
a part of your show.
-Absolutely. She's been, like,
so generous and open
about this from the very,
very get-go.
She was in our pilot
that we shot here in Chicago.
And we just raised money,
and she got paid 125 bucks.
You know, the SAG scale.
I mean, just outrageously kind.
And yeah, and we -- you know,
she's never asked us to, like,
change, like, "Oh, please don't
say this about my character,
or please" --
She's just been totally willing
to have those conversations, and
we have them off screen, too.
I mean, you know, we're just
not totally in the same space.
And I have to say,
when Pat came out, I loved Pat.
And I think really, it's --
and I understand, like,
it's problematic.
But I think it's also, anytime,
like, people are like, "Oh, wow,
there's somebody who I don't
like walking down the street.
Let me use this thing
as a bigoted." You know?
Which is always a delight.
You know, Seth? I mean, come on.
It's hard enough to leave
the house, my man.
Come on, dawg. Anyways.
Nobody's yelling it out as like,
"Hey, hi, Pat!"
You know, it's just like --
It's not filled with
a lot of hubbub-hubbub.
You know what I'm talking about.
-Hey, first of all, I'm so happy
that you were here.
Congratulations on the show.
It's such an accomplishment.
And, hopefully next time you can
be here with us in person.
-That's an honor.
And also I really feel this is
going to go into "Corrections."
"Corrections -- we never should
have had McEnany on."
[ Laughter ]
So, I don't know.
I'll check it out. I'll check it
out on Friday, okay?
-Well, anything to draw eyes to
"Corrections."
You know, anything.
If we can just get you
to promise to watch it,
that would mean --
-I've got four eyes here, sweet.
So I got it.
Seth, seriously, it's an honor.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
The second season of
"Work in Progress"
airs Sunday on Showtime.